foreign
[Music]
welcome ladies and gentlemen
now we are going to talk about
large models and how to operationalize
them using cloud tpus in gke
I know it's end of the day
and it may be
at the point of getting tiring but I
promise you we are also going to talk
about magic
can I get some enthusiasm in the air now
[Applause]
okay
my name is vaibhav Singh I'm a product
manager for cloud TPU and joining me
today for this talk is
a generator where I lead from light
tricks and Matt Hoffman who is a machine
learning engineer from weights and
biases
in the next 45 minutes here is what we
are going to discuss
we're going to discuss why large models
what are the complexities of
operationalizing large models and how
cloud tpus in GK help you address these
complexities
we're going to hear from you off about
how lightrix is using Cloud tpu's NGK
for their production workloads
and we're going to look into how Cloud
GPU in gke is a foundational layer that
lends itself for developing with other
third-party tools the more robust ml Ops
for your large models
and finally we're going to hear from
Matt what weights and biases is building
with cloud tpus in gke so let's get
started
so first of all why large models I think
it's by by this time of the day it's
pretty obvious to everybody or I should
say by this time of the year it's pretty
obvious to everybody but still
large models are generating and
delivering value
across the use cases such as question
answering
such as image generation
coding assistance
the ability to use a model Supply it
with the text prompt and get a useful
work done out of it
is borderline magical
would you agree it is borderline magical
so so that was the magic promise
everybody
so this tweet from Andre karapati who is
one of the co-founders of open AI some
set up the best English is the hardest
new programming language so in case you
did not pay attention to your computer
science classes now is your chance to
program
large models unlock even newer
capabilities with scale some of you may
have seen this chart this is from our
Palm launch blog where it shows that at
different scale we have models acquiring
unique capabilities but these
capabilities also require more model
parameters and data sizes and hence more
compute
and
this is why Google Cloud brings the best
of cloud tpus and gpus so that you can
build your large-scale ml infrastructure
that is cost efficient high performance
and sustainable
however
infrastructure itself is not important
because those of you who have tried to
put a simple model in production
know that operationalization is hard and
operationalizing large models is harder
and why so because at the large scale
there is a complex interplay of many
moving pieces we need a orchestrator a
foundational orchestrator which frees
you up from developing foundational work
such as automatic logging monitoring so
that you are not developing code for it
such as efficient utilization of
resource something that helps you do it
out of the box so that you're not
writing your own queuing system
such as data Providence and model
provenance using either the native
capability of the orchestrator or
something third party that easily plugs
into that orchestrator
and in addition to that an orchestration
which can support a unique computational
capabilities or unique interactions that
we get to see when we are working with
use cases such as reinforcement learning
where there is an actor learner and set
of environments and their data flowing
back and forth between all these moving
pieces and finally we need an
orchestrator
for larger scale that can handle that
skill reliably that can run your
trainings recover from failures recover
from maintenance events gracefully
and if you're using
your production systems which is serving
millions or even thousands of users you
are already probably relying
for Mission critical workloads on gke
for your machine learning workloads
which is using gpus also probably you
are relying on gke but for your machine
learning workloads using tpus until now
you have probably something like this
this is copyrights all all rights
reserved to me
my auto scale Auto resume
large scale
bash dot sh and if you have such a
script in place probably your devops
friends are not coming to your parties
so instead imagine a world where
operationalization
orchestration was simpler
imagine a simple answer to all the
orchestration question that is gke
and this is why we have introduced the
first party integration for cloud tpus
in GK that means now you can create TPU
resources in GK in the same way you can
a GPU or a CPU resource and you can use
kubernetes API to then interact with
these resources
and for those of you even though I would
ask them why did you sign up for this
session if you did not know what is gke
but here is my favorite definition of GK
GK is a cheat code
that helps you focus on using kubernetes
rather than managing it and more
formally it it it is a Google managed
flavor of kubernetes that abstracts away
the control plane so that you are not
managing your cluster and you're
focusing on your operations
back to tpus now I said that there is a
first party integration of tpus it's
first class supported you're asking okay
so what can I do with it
my answer is you can do pretty much
anything you can do with Cloud tpus
otherwise but here are three things that
I want you to walk away with today you
can run training on cloud tpus add
hundreds of or even thousands of Chip
scale that's that's what we call a
single slice Cloud TPU training you can
run training at tens of thousands of
scale for those of you who are in room
number 154 next door we just had a
session that talked about how with Cloud
TPU v5e and our unique multi-slice
technology now we can scale to tens of
thousands of chips beyond the boundaries
of a single ICI domain
so now you can run those training easily
manage them gracefully using gke and
third last but not the least you can do
inference generating value from all
these large models that you are trying
to operationalize okay let's dive into
the training itself so if you are if
you're training with that my favorite
Custom Auto Bash
script today then likely your
painstakingly set setting up a training
environment on every worker of a TPU VM
and then you're writing your script and
launching via SSH onto all these workers
imagine what this setup looks like if
you're working with a slice with 1000
workers
pretty brittle huh tpus in GK is here to
save the day and that's why this
developer on the right hand side is
actually happy now the previous one was
very bored because she was not motivated
writing that my custom script so now she
can write their Jacks writer jacks
tensorflow or pie torch training job
using a simple manifest that uses the
index job API which easily encapsulates
the training environment easily
specifies what is the shape of compute
it needs and finally mentions what is a
script that needs to be run
and gke will take care of the rest
so enough about talking that how it is
simple and easy how about seeing this in
action so let's see a quick demo
all right I think this
needs to be extended here
all right I did not do my offering to
the demo of gods as they said
so uh can everyone see my screen
okay so here I'm creating a GK cluster
and adding a TPU node pool to it this is
a V5 e TPU node pool this is a part
slice with uh 128 35e chips now I'm
showing you the workload manifest here I
am showing to this distinct sections of
this manifest one is this headless
service another is the index job API we
are using headless Service Such that
each of the parts that is created by the
index job
can have a unique DNS entry which is
used for cluster Discovery mechanism and
then I'm simply mentioning my
training container image and specifying
my training script here this training
run is going to train a 16 billion
parameter language model using 128 chips
and as you can see within a single line
of cube CTL my training is already
working within a few seconds
and now I can see the logs
and within a few seconds you will see
the training will get started as you can
see here we have 128 TPU chips in this
cluster
and the training has started now and it
is already producing a hundred and seven
tea flops or teraflops per chip that is
delivering close to 55 percent of model
flop utilization and you may have heard
a claim that we are delivering 2x
performance per dollar with V5 e with
respect to V4 here is this claim now
jumping to our monitoring UI you see
that to TPU specific Matrix which have
been added these monitoring dashboards
are generated automatically without you
writing a single line of code automatic
logging I I again did not have to write
any code for that and I can build
sophisticated dashboard profile for my
training performance here is a brief
view of the profiler itself beginning
with the overview page and jumping to
operational profiling page where you can
see what are the categories of different
operation and what is the fraction of
the step time consumed by these
operations jumping to the graph viewer
page where you can double click into the
fusions or the kernels generated by xla
jumping to the trace viewer page where
you can see or zoom into the step time
itself and see that what are the
operations which are the bottlenecks for
your training run so that you can go and
try to optimize these operations and
finally the memory viewer page which
gives you the view of the hbm allocation
for the lifetime of your program in a
single training step so this was a quick
view of our training run and by this
time
my 15-step training has finished
oh yes
thank you so
so far we talked about
128 chip scale how about tens of
thousands of Chip scale
this is what I refer to as what is
enabled by Cloud TPU multi-slice so it
is a technology that extends the same
programming abstraction that xla brings
for a single slice and extends it to
tens of thousands of chips which can
span across hundreds of these slices as
you can see in this performance chart
which is showing you the scaling curve
measured on training a 175 billion gpt3
model
measured across ranging from 256 ship
all the way to 32768 of V5 e chips and
this is the linear scaling that is the
core value proposition of cloud tpus and
mind you with the same programming
abstraction that you have used so that
as a developer you continue to write
your code as if it is going to run on a
single host or a single chip and it can
automatically scale to these tens of
thousands of chips that being said I
think the core of this talk is
orchestration and operationalization so
how about operationalizing it 32 000
chip cluster that translates to 8 000
VMS now for those of you who have tried
to manage a cluster or run a large-scale
training job know that it is not trivial
managing your training and run it in a
reliable way at this scale or the skill
Beyond it is not simple and this is
where cloud tpus in gke will bring you
The Experience here once again following
the same concept as XLE expands the same
programming model from one chip to
thousands of or tens of thousands of
Chip with gke we are expanding the same
abstraction you saw how the index job
API was used to basically Express a part
sliced training job that runs on to all
the VMS inside that part size now this
job set API is
going to create a manifest that is
going to automatically generate the
underlying set of index job which will
then run onto these hundreds of Parts
slices and not only that this is going
to execute this in a way that is fairly
resilient that is going to automatically
recover from a multiple chip failure or
set of Maintenance events and so on and
at the same time giving you all the out
of the box benefits that GK offers
here's a quick view of our manifest as
you can see that you think the job set
API we are also able to specify the
workload almost in exactly the same way
that we were in case of the index job
API that you saw earlier
so finally in summary Cloud TPU
multi-slice gives you the unique ability
to scale to tens of thousands of Chip
scale and Cloud TPU multi-slice in gke
allows you to orchestrate it in the
easiest possible Manner and gracefully
finally to the third workload remember I
talked about three things the single
slice training the multi-slice training
and finally the inference here I am
showing you an example of running
inference on cloud tpv5e what you're
seeing in the bottom of the screen is a
little interesting demo you can also see
this live at our Hardware Wars Booth but
more crucially with TPU v5e we are
bringing for the first time a TPU VM
shape that can range from one chip to
eight chips and if you have gke node
pools of this kind of TPU VM it can also
Auto Scale based on your workload based
on your traffic and hence it it lends
itself to building production workloads
for serving these amazing models that
you're building with tpus in GK
with this I will now call upon you have
from lightrix who is going to share with
us what is light tricks and how lightrix
is using Cloud TPU of NGK in production
thank you yeah thank you
[Applause]
my name is joab I'm a researcher and I
lead the core generative AI team at
Matrix
with light tricks we bridge the gap
between imagination and creation we have
several Market leading apps
facetune photo leap video leap and
others were our users generate more than
200 million images per month using
generative AI
I want to tell you about our journey
with personalized generative AI
how we learned to prioritize ease of use
in high quality results
over quick response when this trade-off
is necessary
and how we eventually got the best of
Two Worlds
since the early days of stick to image
our goal has been to empower users to
incorporate their own faces and content
into their creations
look at this photo of yours truly
I made it using an old version of our
personalized text to image feature
I'm pretty happy with how it turned out
but I'll be honest it required some
serious prompt engineering skills
while a skilled prompt engineer could
work their magic to achieve convincing
results
more often than not the outcome wasn't
exactly flattering
to address this issue we came up with a
solution
training a custom model for each user
this approach helped us preserve their
unique identity
while it was more costly
and significantly increased latency it
proved to be necessary
shortly after resolving the
personalization challenge
we teamed up with Paramount for an epic
Dungeons and Dragons campaign centered
around this very feature
the campaign had a tremendous impact on
our app not only did it double the
number of exports but it also
significantly increased user retention
even after the conclusion of the
campaign
later this year we achieved some
technological breakthroughs that allowed
us to offer a lightweight alternative to
training a custom model for each user
this alternative is not only way faster
but also better preserves the user's
identity
the idea was to guide the output image
using an image provided by the user
rather than generating it entirely from
scratch
and we didn't stop there we took the
concept further and expanded it Beyond
selfie images this time we allowed
customization for various types of
images including rooms buildings and
landscapes
provided by the user we use these images
as a guide to generate amazing scenes
such as Lego and Barbie inspired
creations
finally users are able to incorporate
their content into generative AI without
compromising on user experience
preserving user identity and the
structure of their content emerged into
an exciting Tick Tock trend showcasing
the creative potential of this feature
users love to see AI generated images of
themselves
the following month the new features
sparked a trend in the United States
particularly among iOS users including
paying subscribers
the significant news is that photo is
the photo labor app made its way into
the top five free apps in the App Store
top 5 surpassing even Tick Tock and
Instagram
the graph indicates the number of
subscribers who've been with us for over
30 days
and we can observe we can observe that
they also join the trend elevating the
overall user base
so that's how we optimized the product
and enabled users to use their content
with generative AI
now let me tell you about the
infrastructure behind this magic
we built our training infrastructure on
top of tpuv4
we store our data in small shards on
Google cloud storage and we stream these
shards to the TPU VMS in training time
the TPU VMS upload checkpoints
periodically to then to another GCS
Bucket from which a lightweight GPU
machine downloads them and generates
results for evaluation
TPU parts are treated atomically in
other words either all CPU cores are
working or they all diet once this helps
us to recover from Hardware failure
failures and resume the training when
needed
recently we've started to use TPU in gke
rather than setting up the TPU machines
directly in GCE
now we're able to use Docker images in
other kubernetes features that save us
many custom scripts and add more
flexibility to our workflow
while the overhead of creating a cluster
and then a separate pool for each
topology is high using TPU and gke opens
up opportunities for us that weren't
possible before with GCE
one important advantage of the TPU Parts
is the linear scaling
here you see that the number of images
per second goes up linearly with the
number of TPU cores
this is very important for us when
training our text to image Foundation
models
these advantages of TPU as well as our
careful data curation process in some
architectural improvements enable us to
train our foundation text to image model
much faster and for an order of
magnitude less money than it took to
train stable diffusion on a cluster of
gpus
our in-house models are tailored to our
needs enabling us to efficiently
generate hundreds of millions of images
per month thanks to higher throughput
and better control
if you are interested in hearing more
details about generative Ai and light
tricks you're welcome to come to the TPU
Hardware verse booth and will be there
thank you back to you if I have
[Applause]
10x cost reduction these are the kind of
numbers that brings me out of the better
every morning because someone somewhere
is using tpus and now tpus in gke to
drive home these kind of savings and
achieving this in this level of
efficiency
moving on coming back to the same
picture that we saw earlier in terms of
complexity of large-scale orchestration
I hope that you have seen in action
through our demo and heard from you off
as well on how cloud tpus in gke is
helping to address some of these
complexities as a foundational
orchestrator as a base layer that lenses
itself so that you can use your
resources in the most efficient possible
way
and as a out of the box
logging monitoring profiling
and all these toolings which can help
you then debug and solve any problems
that you run into
now that being said
we also realize that all your problems
would not be solved at the at the native
GK solution level itself
you would need to also leverage other
ecosystem tools in order to have
features such as model provenance data
provenance and much more
and this is where the the role of cloud
tpus in GK as a foundational
orchestrator comes into play and now I'm
going to call upon Matt from recent
biases who is going to tell us what
weights and vices is building with cloud
tpus in GK Matt
[Applause]
EXP
erience and biases so I'm going to talk
to you today about how we're making it
really easy for all of our customers and
ml Engineers to access the power of tpus
even if they don't know how to use
cubectl so first off what's weights and
biases so our mission at w and B is
building the best ml tools out there for
ML practitioners and so we have sort of
a wide-ranging platform covering a lot
of features for you know tracking all of
the the results from your model
trainings like yoab was was just talking
about visualizing collaborating on that
data with your colleagues and some sort
of newer features
um around sort of llm Ops as well
and so we have you know customers
ranging from you know the small scale
generative AI startups all the way to
some of the largest players in the space
using us for a few common workflows you
know training your experiments managing
and viewing sort of the lineage of data
sets to models supercharging or
collaboration and sort of you know
getting a path to production ready
models
so what does that look like in practice
so over here on the left you can see a
screenshot where you know all of your
training runs or evaluation jobs whether
they're happening in gke individual GC
instances sort of local notebooks all
that is going to be gathered together
um and will also sort of generate some
some default charts for that
and then there's additional data there
as well so for a particular model over
there on the left that dag can take you
all the way back to which data sets when
which versions of data sets were used
especially for folks that have new data
coming online being able to answer that
senior executive to say this is what was
in our pipeline when it was trained very
very important and on the right we're
capturing a whole host of additional
data so the the code Docker images that
were used to to run that system metrics
GP utilization all of that
and so you know we had this feature set
and over the past year so we're speaking
with customers and sort of heard this
recurring pain point right so you know
we need a reliable way to spin up lots
of training runs
um folks doing sort of big hyper
parameter sweeps you know scaling things
out we're having sort of blockages in
there in their pipeline
you know folks complaining about
training runs taking uh up to two weeks
multiple weeks
um to sort of finish uh sort of slowing
down the the pace of innovation there
and I think you know this engineer put
it very well you know those even when
you have that solved there's a lot of
manual developer work
um to do those things we've been talking
about today get all those scripts ready
um and just sort of asking us you know
could we just get a quick easy button to
access the the power of cloud compute
and so we launched this feature called
launch and have been making lots of puns
about launching launch uh earlier this
year
um really sort of focused on that pain
point right so connecting ml
practitioners with that High
um High scale specialized Hardware like
tpus
um and making it you know really easy
for the ml Engineers we work with not
just folks that are you know very
familiar with ML Ops you know in
practice working with folks what we've
really found is you know you can bring
them together the ml Ops person can run
those fancy commands and get all the
tpus
um available to use and then connect
them to a place where the ml Engineers
are already working so with sort of the
the gke support for tpus now we're able
to launch the you know Docker images
code requirements all of that
information straight into gke so you can
sort of from one simple easy button
connect so you can see here one run in W
and B
from the interface we can see all of the
model configs you can change your data
sets change you know your training speed
and then you can see here the ml Ops
engineer already has this connected to
tpus and boom you know that is now off
running in gke with no need for the ml
Engineers to have to do anything other
than log code to W and B and then rely
on that you know config setup 13 lines
of code you know one time setup and then
you're good to go
so with that
um bring vibhab back up to tie it all
together
thank you
thank you Matt
Cloud tpus NGK with a click of a button
with 13 lines of code how wonderful that
is thank you for the work that weights
and vices is doing and congratulations
on the launch of launch sorry I could
not resist that joke
so coming back to our complexity picture
I hope that now you have seen that we
have a platform that can address
orchestration operationalization for
your large-scale ml workloads
comprehensively right from out of the
box capabilities and also leveraging
other ecosystems of which you saw one
example
so in summary what are the three
takeaways number one Cloud tpus are here
in gke you heard three primary workloads
the single slice training the
multi-slice training and also running
inference is now possible and not only
possible but you can do it easily and
efficiently
second it is already delivering on the
promise uh lightrix is already using
cloud tpus in production and there are
many such customers who are leveraging
the power of gke with Cloud tpus to
solve their large model orchestration
and finally as a substrate or the base
layer or the foundational orchestrator
cloud tpus in GK is already lending
itself
for you to leverage other ecosystem
tools such as weights and biases so that
you can create your own flavor of
ml apps for your large-scale model
orchestration thank you very much
foreign